year review welcome everybody to where i
complain about youtube rewind our yearly
edition 2018. last year i uploaded
why am i not in youtube rewind 2017.
what reason could they possibly have
how could they you know maybe the answer
to that
was pretty obvious just me just maybe
but as you probably know if you watched
2018 i'm not in this one
as well although this year they uh they
told me at least which i
which i appreciate i am not in it big
surprise
i know it wasn't because i said no it
was because i wasn't asked
yeah no it's it's cool 2017 has been
quite the year and here i am one year
later i know yeah it's cool 2018 has
been quite a year
still can't swear now no a lot of you
guys wanted me to be in youtube rewind
to do that
uh year review i almost said meme review
i saw a lot of people tweeting about it
and it's been everywhere on my uh
on my reddit i want pewdiepie to do year
review
youtube rewind is that puget is not in
it you know what to do
youtube let's not add pewdiepie youtube
rewind youtube riemann gets the most
dislikes
youtube ah what all right we need some
ideas for you to rewind
fortnite dancing let's get ninja how
about
pewdiepie starting with your
being angry that pewdiepie isn't in
youtube rewind being happy that
pewdiepie isn't in the worst video ever
created
wow was it that bad we'll go through it
in a minute
first speculation time lily punch
liza koji david dobrik
you link it late night show hosts
some political [ __ ] uh
lily stinks i don't know let's just
watch it
how bad can it really be come on why is
everyone complaining about this year's
rewind
let's frickin do this guys
is that will smith okay guys this is
already epic
remember when will smith jump out of the
bungee helicopter thing
that was really cool that was happening
at the same time as the
the logan paul uh in case sci fi
fighting match which i had people
actually watching it
i mean no this is epic yeah it's rewind
time
you know if i control rewind i would
want
fortnite
no you don't will smith i want fortnite
telling lies telling sweet little lies
why do i get the feeling that will smith
never played fortnite
and marquez brownlee marquez brownlee
marcus brownlee marquez marcus brownlee
mark case
sorry my case it sounds like it says
mark ass
and marquez brownlee is that how you
pronounce it my i thought it was monkey
[Music]
is this what you wanted you know who i
would have asked for
quit horsing around let me see oh my god
it's ninja yeah
a quick little meme
[Music]
is this what you wanted you know who i
would have asked for
the [ __ ] you say to me okay that's epic
so guys
apparently we control rewind this year
y'all we can do whatever we want
what do we do well you clearly messed up
didn't
you this is why you don't leave it up to
the youtubers
there's one thing this video needs
k-pop
okay so apparently this was a
controversial thing because they use bts
uh despite apparently youtube deleting
views from the bts video
so so bts fans are are very angry about
this
me sharing bts pardon you to rewind so
that no one has to
watch it there and give them views you
can't use us for views
take revenge bts aren't in it anyway
they didn't even mention their name
just called it k-pop s-m-h
this is how angry i was when they
unfollowed me on twitter
what what bongo cat
they got freaking bug okay who put pongo
cat
i want to know who put bongo cat in in
youtube rewind he said rewind did
approach me asking for bonker cat so i
drew him
up with a little top hat for those
frames oh that's so cute
oh yeah apparently these videos are
really popular whether you just eat
grilled food
in korea you sit in front of the camera
and you just eat food
how can you just make that content
they're not even reacting to other
people's content
how can you call that content
what's the reference there is that the
reference to the gif of the
of the dog that's right i say gif
uh all right whatever okay we got more
bts in coming
and bongo cat again oh was that a
brofist
was that a freaking brofist
that's cool that they have animators
oh i wish i didn't see that
why
[Music]
oh i can't handle this
this has been all over my twitter
yesterday pewdiepie's chair made it in
i can't thank you jaden animations for
sneaking in
the pewdiepie chair when your goddamn
chair has more
respect and clap than you have i think
it's just time for me to step down
and just let my chair take over
hey yes
bravo i wonder if youtube actually knew
that that was the chair
and if they knew what they had said no
i'm really curious about that
fortnite damn that was another great
reference i really enjoyed that one
we should read the comments
you know what let's let's read the
comments why don't we read the comments
what does the comment say don't want to
watch the video political issues in
fortnight you're welcome
here before two million dislikes
in my next series it gets worse no
t-series versus pewdiepie reference mr
beast
thanos tick-tock already tracer oh that
would have been great case i was logan
you got a knuckles jake paul deji
god's plan logan paul did
buddy stan lee yeah what the hell x
extension
and stefan carl as well maybe it shows
up later
no it isn't where the hell there it is
where the hell is my boy stephen carl
yeah
that's really that's really lame i'm
honestly more disappointed
that they didn't have stefan carl than
anything let's give the people what they
[Music]
want that was the
aloha that was the goal of this rewind
let's give the
everyone control for rewind everyone
let's give the people what they want
this year
last year was a total failure this year
we need to do better
[Music]
oh i was so worried they were not gonna
have lily puns in there for a second oh
my god thank god
all right now it's now it's epic
no i don't know what the futbol is
okay that's it
yeah i guess asmr is a thing
[Music]
fortnite fortnite ford knives and maybe
some other thing is that
is that a reference is that a logan paul
reference here's a crazy idea
maybe not shoot anything in the woods of
course fortnite is going to be a big
thing just because dancing is so big so
they kind of memed it a little bit
oh that's hot that's hot that's
definitely gonna become a meme
[Music]
oh that's hot that's hot each year
each rewind seems more and more
disconnected from its video
creators and viewers 48 000 likes
maybe that's why they thought okay let's
make the
everyone decide what it is maybe i don't
know
ah it's rewind time
quit horsing around play me some of that
jumping music
i'm already
[Laughter]
why are we still here
just to suffer every night this is pain
feel my leg
pure torture okay so that was youtube
rewind
2018 what do you guys think of it
emperor lemme posted this on twitter
these are all the bars
and this like and dislike over the years
2012 2013
it reached peak somewhere 2013 2014 and
then 2015 it started to go down
and this year heavily it was almost like
people
wanted to dislike it before it even came
out because
the communities is more unhappy with
youtube than ever he also tweeted i
thought it was interesting personally i
think the old era has been gone for a
while and corporation already control
youtube
you can't stop the corporate takeover
but by the same token you can't stop
people from caring about
what has been lost i remember i mean
everyone remembers
rewind was something that it was it
seemed at least like an homage
to the creators that year it was
something cool to be part of
now it's almost like i'm i'm almost glad
that i'm not in it because it's such a
cringy video at this point
it's so disconnected with the community
and its creators
when it's trying to even do the opposite
do the ones that
make youtube rewind actually watch
youtube it seems so disconnected i mean
it would be funny if youtube rewind got
demonetized well
they spent literally millions and
millions and millions on these so
i think it's safe to say they did they
included this
youtube rewind 2013 predicts lasagna
wow to be fair the production is always
great on these
i think that some of the songs were
really good it almost begs the question
is it impossible to make a good rewind
we know from previous years that they
made some
some great videos that people are
genuinely happy with but now
you know before there was maybe like 50
channels
that had the over a million subscribers
now it's over 2 000 channels that had
over a million subscribers so
to really get everyone in there and to
really please everyone this is going to
be impossible
so it's definitely harder to pull this
kind of stuff off now than it was before
if i had to do a rewind i would focus
you know what i
i would cut everyone that is in it every
year
there's always the 10 20 people that are
in it every single year for some reason
like lily pons and lily sings and
marques i do like marquez though but
still they're in it every single year i
would and i would just say okay this
year
we're just gonna do uh the upcoming
youtubers or
this year we're just gonna do the actual
trends because there's no way they're
gonna be able to hit every youtuber
anyway
and just the youtubers that made the
most impact that year
because i think that's why people don't
like these videos because that's
definitely not what was in the video
what do you guys think do you think next
year will uh will be better or do you
think it will be worse it seems like
people aren't really optimistic i wonder
really
how they would turn this around to be
honest but yeah
that was it for this video hope you guys
enjoyed it smash like subscribe if you
enjoyed
that's right i need more subscribers
definitely need more
bye
oh that's hot that's hot
[Music]
[Applause]
you